اكثر من ع انفجارات قويه هزت مباني كيف
امطرت روسيا العاصمه الاوكرانيه بالصواريخ
صباحا اصدرت السلطات العسكريه تحذيرات
جويه استمرت لثلاث ساعات على الاقل شضايا
من حطام الصواريخ الروسيه سقطت في عدد من
مناطق كياف وطل بعضها مباني سكنيه حريق
هائل اندلع بداخل هذا المبنى بحسب رئيس
بلديه كيف فان محيط بنيه تحتيه مدنيه تعرض
للقصف وعانت اربع مناطق من قطاع التيار
الكهربائي ومشكله في ضخط
المياه تم الان اجلاء جميع السكان امراه
مسنه كانت في طريقها الى المستشفى توفيت
للاسف متاثره بجروحها اما في خاركيف جمالا
فادت اربع ضربات على الاقل الى تضرر مبان
عده اضافه الى بنى تحتيه مدنيه وسط
المدينه اعلن الرئيس الاوكراني في فيديو
على تليغرام ان الروسيا اطلقت 99 صاروخا
من انواع مختلفه على
اوكرانيا لقد استخدموا ما يقارب 100 صاروخ
من انواع مختلفه وتم اسقاط ما لا يقل عن
70 صاروخا 60 منها في منطقه كيف اشكر كل
من يقدم لنا المساعده من الواضح ان انظمه
الدفاع الجوي مثل باتريوت وايس تساعد كل
يوم في انقاذ حياه المئات اما الجيش
الروسي فقد اعلن تدمير جميع اهدافه عبر
تلك الضربات اتت هذه الهجمات بعد ساعات
فقط من تعهد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
بان موسكو ستكثف ضرباتها على اهداف عسكريه
في اوكرانيا ردا على هجوم اوكراني غير
مسبوق على مدينه بيلغورد الروسيه